(cop show music)
- [Radio] Car 67,
come in car 67.
- This is car 67,
- we're code five,
- code five,
- nothing to report.
- we've got nothing to report.
(saxophone)
(car horn honking)
- 1:14 a.m.
- You don't have
to put this on it.
- Moses falls asleep, hits
head on steering wheel,
honks horn, gets
slobber all over car.
- I think we can leave
that out of the report.
- Why, you wanna do
everything by the book,
right, big guy? Huh?
Finished, written in stone.
There ya go.
What do ya see?
- Nothing, just a...
- Oh shit, he's breaking in.
Come on, let's go.
- You don't know that!
- He's peeking in
the window, Moses.
- That doesn't mean
he's breaking in.
- Look at him.
- [Moses] Okay, loitering,
maybe, public intoxication,
maybe, but I'm not wasting
my time on a loiterer
just because you're
uncomfortable with a,
certain type of person.
- Certain type of person?
Are you calling me what I
think you're calling me?
- You know good and well
that's what you were thinking.
- No, I was thinking, his
actions are suspicious.
- I'm just saying, we
shouldn't jump to conclusions
just because this fine
gentleman is African American.
- Oh, there's a,
there's a conclusion.
There's a racist
conclusion right there.
How do you know he's
African American, huh?
He could be African Jamaican,
he could be African
Luxembourgian,
how do you know?
(glass shatters)
Oh, shit--
- No, hey, hey.
He's probably drunk and has
to break into his house,
because he doesn't a key.
Who in this car can
understand being drunk,
and breaking into your own home?
Chance?
- Now that was a pretty
cheap shot, Moses.
I broke into my house
to prove to Theresa
that I've moved on, okay?
- [Moses] By the way, I
don't think it's weird
that a black guy dressed
like that would live
in this neighborhood,
there I said it.
- [Chance] Why do you feel
you have to clarify that?
- [Moses] I mean he's
probably a really
successful record producer.
- Come on!
- Are you really gonna
shoot an African American,
registered firearm owner,
protecting his own home?
Okay, he is a patriot.
- You know what I think?
- Enlighten me, please.
- I think you're worried
that you're a racist,
and if you arrest a black
man, it's gonna prove it.
- [Moses] Okay,
I'm racist, sure.
Would a racist donate
to every single
black Kickstarter out
there, I don't think so.
(woman screams)
- Oh, okay, let me guess.
That's his wife, and he's, uh,
he's come home early to surprise
her, is that what it is?
- Or they're engaging
in some sexual roleplay.
I mean, one time my wife
had me hide in the bushes
and surprise her on
her jogging route.
And then, I surprised her,
I surprised her again,
and then she surprised me.
- Really?
That's pretty hot man.
- Yeah, it's, been a lot
tamer since the kids.
(gunshot, woman screaming)
I voted for Obama!
- I didn't vote but I
live in a blue state!
- [Moses] You should
always try to vote!
You should always vote!
- Same thing, same thing!
(girlish scream)
- What the hell man?
- You are under arrest.
You have the right
to remain silent.
This has nothing to do
with you being black.
Anything you say, can and will--
- Honey, what's happening?
- Classic black sitcom.
- What the hell's going on?
- He was clearly breaking
into your house, ma'am.
- No!
- We are into some
adventurous love making.
I pretend to break in,
and she gets all nasty
and into it, it's
fantasy motherfucker.
And then, you tackled
me right on my dick.
Feels all twisted,
like maybe he broke it.
- You can't break a dick.
- You can break a dick.
- You can break a dick?
- Very much so, yes.
(girlish scream)
- Neighborhood watch, stay down!
- We're cops, get
off of me you idiot!
- As far as I can tell, ya'll
just a couple of white dudes
with guns up to no good.
- Nobody holds up a
successful record producer
in my neighborhood.
- Record producer,
I called that.
- [Neighborhood Watch]
Keeping property values high,
motherfucker.
- That's what we do.